je tire un petit jeu avant ou après when
they knew tube c'était avant 2004 après
2004 à 20 ha ha
avant ou après whitehead le premier
iphone ah bon avant tu dis et non ce
site wat a mano 90 au début avec deux
ans tu vois là mais j'avais c'est ça ben
on donne après avant ou après la wii fit
après avant ou après le western bernard
montiel à la présentation de vidéo gag
bernard montiel ni la prise avant ses
avants et non il y fait vivre en 2003
c'est juste avant justement
et ouais il a attendu que moi je t'aime
jeunesse pour se faire virer avant la
priorité de la tecktonik après on se
rappelle la techno limiter ça ça arrivé
en france en 2006 ah oui et heureusement
c'est vite parti à l'étude
valle mala
c'est tellement c'est très bon c'est
très bon ah bon après wyden netflix
après 20 17
et ouais ça marchait pas du tout avant
et louer des dvd en ligne et c'est qu'en
2007 qui sont mis en vidéo voilà bah
ouais ouais ouais j'ai mis en avant
auprès des jeunes la cigarette
électronique
après c'était avant ce tournoi sont
trois bons étalons et k4 et ça et tout
le monde s'en foutait à l'époque mais
dans l'équipe il ya plein de trucs sur
plus a pas envie de savoir aux
spécialités
bon après weldens les sushis en france a
fait un bond en avant
jasin et c'était en en même temps en
2004 et c'est à cause ou grâce à un
reportage d'envoyé spécial qui pointait
du doigt
l'hygiène des de certains restaurants
beaucoup ont donc fermé et ce sont bien
faire un autre style de cuisine en
exploitant les sushis et la cuisine
japonaise
voilà et c'est pour ça que l'acte et en
2004 les sushis ont témergie si c'est
fou on apprend des trucs les mecs